I truly can't believe this is happening
but Kellyanne Conway a top adviser to
Donald Trump seems to think kovat 19
means that it's the 19th coronavirus of
course kovat 19 is a reference to 2019
the year in which this virus was evolved
emerged was named there's really not
much need for more explanation Donald
Trump yesterday announced that he's
cutting funding to the w-h-o in the
midst of a pandemic it's a disastrous
decision
Kellyanne Conway of course went on Fox
News and she's trying to defend
everything that Donald Trump does trying
to defend Donald Trump from scrutiny
trying to defend Donald Trump's action
in cutting funding to the w-h-o and she
says hey guys come on
this is kovat 19 not kovat 1 the w-h-o
should have figured it out by now and of
course koban 19 just means coronavirus
disease from the Year 2019
here's Kellyanne in her full glory the
president took decisive and immediate
action the end of January to shut down
flights from China that was criticized
by the whu-oh it was criticized by other
people as in a phobic and racist and
travel bans don't work well this one
sure did so we have every right to know
and every right to know because of
what's happened here in this global
pandemic but there's another reason some
of the scientists and doctors say that
there could be other strains later on
this can come back in the fall in a
limited way this is Cova 19 not covered
one folks and so you would think the
people charged with the World Health
Organization facts and figures would be
on top of that that this is just a pause
right now so there's an investigation
examination to what happened but people
should know the facts how dystopian is
it that she ends with people should know
the facts despite spreading something
that is not a fact but is rather
completely false propaganda
this is kovat nineteen folks not kovat
one that's just the year this isn't the
19th coronavirus i hope that all of you
understand the implication which is if
this is the 19th such coronavirus how
the hell has the w-h-o not prepared
during coronaviruses 1 through 18 that's
not what it means
it just means this is the 2019
coronavirus that's it now I suspect and
I'm curious what you think I suspect
Kellyanne Conway knows that kovat 19
doesn't mean this is the 19th
coronavirus I think she knows it means
it's the 2019 coronavirus I think
Kellyanne Conway is saying this because
she's on Fox and it's likely to stick
with a ton of their viewers this was a
sort of useful to me and that I thought
the movie k-9 cop was the ninth movie
and I've been asking my mom since I was
a little kid can't we rent you know k9k
cop one through one through eight turns
out they weren't really movies turns a
new leaf over for blink 182 now I'm
understanding where are all of the other
bands many questions really being
answered for me by Kellyanne Conway here
but this is a top advisor to the
president top advisor I do thank Kelly
Anne Conway to remind the audience that
kovat 19 by mentioning 2019 is another
reminder that this was around last year
Trump did nothing until February but it
was identified last year we started
tracking it last year we were following
case numbers last year not in late
February when Donald Trump finally
started doing something about it
now one other word about the WHL Trump
announced yesterday he's cutting funding
to the w-h-o talked a lot about China or
China as he calls it and it's a lot of
blame shifting and trying to blame
everybody and take no responsibility
just because Trump said he's cutting
funding to the w-h-o doesn't mean he
actually is and I'm not saying anything
other than Trump has many times
announced that he's doing things and
then he never does it
remember when he announced the
transgender military ban while his then
Secretary of State Secretary of Defense
was who knows where nobody knew about it
and then it wasn't ever actually done
and nobody talks about it anymore
very often Donald Trump will announce
something and then it doesn't really
happen that doesn't mean it's right to
announce it if he's not actually doing
it all I'm saying is Trump made an
announcement of something that is a bad
idea
we don't actually know what
it's going to happen he claims it is we
don't know because he lies all the time
there's a YouTube channel called up flip
that we're partnering with I would love
for you to check it out I've put the
link right underneath the video make
sure to subscribe to the channel when
you're there up flip is a channel that
is all about exploring small business
and what makes a small business
successful every episode interviews an
entrepreneur you take a tour of the
business and these are not generic
interviews you actually get a really
fascinating deep dive into the history
of the business the mistakes the
entrepreneur made what they learned what
motivates them what a day is like
running their business and you get all
sorts of super interesting and valuable
insight about what it's like to run that
type of small business as a business
owner myself I find up flips videos to
be endlessly intriguing even if you
don't own your own business
it is really great for a general
audience it's stuff that I think just
about anybody would find fascinating and
you can check it out by going to david
pakman.com slash up flip the link is
right underneath this video when you're
there make sure to subscribe and click
the bell for notifications